E aí
é reconhecida que que diz que se nós
conhecermos a história alguém é
impossível odiar mas essa pessoa eu
parti para um dos bastante longínquos
com a vontade de entregar os meus saber
onde eles também ainda mais necessários
e esta vontade exercer medicina de
salvar vidas levou-me a conhecer mundos
que a maioria das pessoas fiz que não
existe mas existe eu enquanto o médico
tem de exercer a minha profissão melhor
que sei e com as minhas palavras tento
trazer as vozes que eu tenho no meu
coração e depois da minha primeira
missão na República democrática do Congo
eu tive a oportunidade de fazer uma
viagem super bonita por alguns países
africanos e quando estava a ler o guia
da Lonely Planet eu tive a curiosidade
de saber o que é que eles diziam sobre o
leste do Congo e diziam qualquer coisa
como a guerra já tinha acabado
Oi e eu comecei a chorar baba e ranho
Por que para mim eram as histórias
destas pessoas que estão a sofrer com
este terrível conflito armado que é
provavelmente a pior guerra da Segunda
Guerra Mundial e Esta fonte tão credível
de informação de alguma forma fazer-nos
crer que estava tudo bem
a cada vez que eu tenho oportunidade de
falar em público eu eu eu fico nervoso e
por um lado eu faço questão de estar
nervoso porque eu ouço as bombas a cair
nele lembro-me das vidas que eu perdi
nas minhas mãos e engulo a minha revolta
e faço questão de que as coisas não saem
do coração e que sejam sobre eles e não
seja sobre mim algumas histórias são
tristes outras são alegres mas eu tenho
a plena convicção de que o impacto que
nascem nós é para ação EA de felicidade
pela projeção daquilo que nós podemos
fazer
e é muito difícil cantar esta história e
eu acho que também será difícil para
vocês ouvirem na Eu já vi muita coisa
enquanto médico mas como essa história
nunca tinha visto nada parecido foi na
República Centro Africana na capital
bangui eu trabalhava na maternidade e as
altas esta altura aparecermos uma
rapariga de 22 anos
e eu vou lhe chamar Maria a Maria veio
ter connosco a maternidade para fazer um
aborto
e o assunto é polêmico obviamente
eticamente muito discutível mas tendo em
conta aquilo que eu vou contar eu penso
que não há grandes dificuldades de
compreender que a decisão médica era que
esta rapariga precisava fazer um aborto
a Maria tinha sido raptada por um grupo
rebelde um grupo terrorista africano
aqueles grupos que queimam aldeias que
roubam crianças que com catanas com
kalashnikovs cometem aqueles horrores
Que nós às vezes Vemos nos filmes mais
sensacionalistas e achamos que um
exagero mas este tipo de violência em
alguns países africanos é troço é cruel
e atingir uma infinidade de pessoas a
Maria esteve neste cativeiro ambulante
do no leste da República centro-africana
durante muitos meses a Maria foi várias
vezes violada
e ela foi violada por um para virada por
2 foi violado por todos uma vez muitas
vezes até que deixar um para trás no seu
caminho não está bem que eu encontrei
A Maria estava grávida estava
francamente desnutrida uma mulher de uma
estatura média um metro e 65 talvez mais
e pesava 19kg é
eu não tinha expressão facial
é praticamente não comunicado a conosco
estava tão magra Sou magra tão magra que
o outro de oito semanas consegui de
alguma forma adivinhar no seu abdômen
descongelado e muita coisa nós também
não sabíamos porque Maria não conseguia
falar e até já tínhamos algumas dúvidas
se elas teriam não consciente a maior
parte da história foi descontada pelo
marido
É sim foi o marido da Maria Queres que a
trouxe as nossas mãos e normalmente até
frequente nestas zonas da África mais
profunda um de violência sexual é
extremamente frequente as mulheres serem
abandonadas e os precisados pela
comunidade como se o não fosse
suficiente o trauma que elas carregam
muitas vezes para ter que cometem
suicídio pelo abandono das suas
comunidades Mas neste caso ela tinha um
marido ali ao lado que ajudava que nos
contaram históricos preocupava
genuinamente muitas coisas nós não
compreendíamos acho que a maioria das
pessoas não queria se quer compreender o
pouco que não sabemos era o suficiente
para nos dilacerar completamente o
coração e eu lembro que ao ver o marido
ainda mais dolorosa ficava a história
sentiu uma certa de um certo ricos Eu Te
deste desta história de terror esta
pressão horrível que esta rapariga
sofreu e por consequência aumenta minha
família direita a nossa estratégia era
salvar-lhe a vida
há também aqueles que de vida ela era a
gravidade da desnutrição tanto
pretendemos alimentá-la até que ela
tivesse alguma condição para poder subir
interromperá a gravidez a
voluntariamente com medo de
farmacológico
e nós estávamos alimentar aos poucos a
Maria Parecia ter uma expressão ela
praticamente Não segurava a mandíbula e
depois passado uns dias a conseguimos de
alguma forma perceber os mitos passaram
a ser palavras ela confia sagrado para
um outro momento até que me chamaram
atenção que ela estava a começar a ter
crises epilépticas epilepsia ou as
crises epilépticas não são a doença por
si só é um sintoma muitas doenças e eu
não tenho assim também tanta experiência
com desnutrição grave não precisa
exatamente qual era o espectro de
sintoma no meio daquela complexidade
toda claro que tentei estudarmos não
tratei sintomaticamente e felizmente as
crises foram diminuindo e passar uns
dias com a ligeiríssima família do
estado geral da Maria traduzir de alguma
forma no sorriso do marido que
aumentando à medida que a Maria ganhava
alguma força nós decidimos então
interromper a sua gravidez tudo correu
bem
e continuou conosco a ser alimentada até
que chegou Aquele momento que agora o
que é que fazemos com a Maria já não é
um problema de maternidade Então me
pressionaram de alguma forma por também
eram entendimento sinalizado que ela
poder ir para um hospital não tivesse no
cemitério Neurologia dizemos até fazer
um eletroencefalograma mas conhecendo a
qualidade dos hospitais nestes países
aparecimento das um quem inverosímil mas
lá foi
a alergias e o recebi a informação de
que a Maria tinha feito o
eletroencefalograma e que não teria
epilepsia também o eletroencefalograma
uma fotografia do momento uma pessoa
tivesse doente epiléticos não não retira
o diagnóstico tiraram dos
antiepilépticos e passar uns dias eu
recebi a informação de que Maria morreu
e a minha pergunta é quem é que não quer
que matou a Maria Será que foram nestes
animais que a violar um durante meses
Será que a ganância de Quem promove
estas guerras Será que a pobreza da
República centro-africana fragilidade
desta medicina que é tão pobre Será que
somos todos nós que não queremos saber
e eu acho que me dar uma história tem um
poder mágico e com todos os superpoderes
tem que ser acompanhado por uma grande
responsabilidade eu acho que a
responsabilidade é utilizar por um lado
a bondade EA compaixão que deveria ser a
religião todos nós e por outro lado a
representatividade quantas vidas quantas
histórias é que a história da Maria
representa não podemos fazer nada pela
Maria mas há muitas Marias uma história
dor de ontem e certamente de amanhã
muita pobreza na África mais profunda a
violência sexual a discriminação de
gênero o casamento infantil o não acesso
pelas mulheres as raparigas a
escolaridade
e é são todos os problemas que fazem com
que na minha opinião não é o feminismo
deve ser deve ter um inspector bastante
mais alargado e por outro lado não é os
conflitos armados com de longe sendo o
cerne do maior problema da humanidade
e eu acho que contar uma história tenho
um poder de nos conectar esta conexão eu
não acredito na vida para além da Morte
mas acredito muito que as pessoas estão
vivas nas nossas memórias e é Maria
Esteves aqui eu apresentei vida Maria
ela de alguma forma participou aqui
nesta nesta conversa a um provérbio
judeu que nos diz o que me pergunta o
que é mais verdade o que é verdade se
umas histórias as histórias por tenha
própria verdade ea representatividade
e eu acredito que dentro da
representatividade nós estamos de alguma
forma a conhecer as personagens da
história mas estamos também a
conhecermos a nós próprios trata-se
também que saber quem nós somos quando
estamos ouvir uma história e aquilo que
nós somos no essencial é um ser que está
morado num círculo numa espécie de um
projeto cultural que é um gueto também
emocional identitário por vezes
religioso em que nós temos completamente
fechados lá dentro e ao cantarem nos uma
história é que nós não mandamos os muros
abaixo nós respeitamos por um buraquinho
nós conseguimos ver para Além Deste
nosso cliente cultural e o conhecimento
que está dentro deste círculo pouco
interessa não acrescenta não me faz
crescer o que mais importa é aquilo que
está fora do Círculo é aquele que nos
faz ser uma pessoa mais completa +
Universal
a razão pela qual eu chorei quando li
que não havia nenhuma guerra na
República democrática do Congo tinha
acabado de sair a quem é que está a
contar estas histórias quem são as
pessoas que estão a contar estas
histórias porque é que não conta umas
histórias daquilo que me parecia ser o
maior problema dos dias de hoje e isso
que não sejam convite para o outro
autismo finalmente nos levar empurrar os
problemas para frente e não fazer nada e
querer saber ainda menos todos os
problemas são importantes a sua dimensão
mas eu acho que a proporção das nossas
atenções deve estar a medida da
importância dos acontecimentos eu Desde
há muito tempo que penso sobre a forma
como a empatia joga na No Poder da
história na dimensão da Notícia porque
há coisas que levantam a nossa empatia
de uma forma Quase inexplicável ele
empatia um enormíssimo poder EA outras
por vezes não representam quase nada e
tem o mesmo efeito eu
nós estamos recordados destas 12
crianças e do seu treinador que
estiveram presos dentro da Gruta dentro
de uma Gruta da Tailândia todo mundo
fica olhar para esta história toda a
gente fiz um Speed sem dinheiro Nós
provavelmente contribuiremos mas aqui
não é não simpatia humanística que está
a falar é espetacular idade da história
é por isto que nós temos que queremos
era saber o desenlace aquilo que nos
parece ser um filme interessante de
compreender e por isso é que temos os
repórteres de todo o mundo inclusive até
a nossa repórter Judite Sousa e depois a
história dentro da história já é a roupa
da Judite de Sousa e que ela recusou
pagar 15.000 euros para dormir não se
vai dormir no chão e depois de cinco
dias estava Exausta na Tailândia suas
férias na Tailândia por dentro nós damos
toda uma dimensão uma história dizendo
que a vida destas duas crianças e por
sinal o mergulhador que perdeu a vida ao
tema de importantíssimo mas estas
crianças tiveram tivesse a morrer de
fome certamente a Judite Sousa e estão
é sobre a senhora é sobre a nossa
relação com a notícia certamente não
estaria no local se não acompanhe o meu
raciocínio onde passado Prêmio Nobel da
Paz alguém se lembra alguém se lembra de
ter tido impacto na sociedade programa
alimentar Mundial Eu lembro que na
altura escreveu um artigo do público e
vou dizer quais eram os temas mais
falados à medida que se falava também
pouco ou Nada se calhar em nota de
rodapé do programa alimentar Mundial e
do prêmio Nobel da Paz foi uma coisa
gravíssima que ministro da saúde disse
que nós hoje em dia não sabemos Quem foi
foi aquilo que alguém diz sobre não sei
o que é dos ciganos e um assunto
importante mas que domina o urso
telejornais e abafou completamente a
sistema e ainda toda uma grande polêmica
sobre um vídeo de relações sexuais
dentro do Comboio que dominaram o
opinião de muitos críticos tantos isto
e representa no ano de 2019 97 milhões
de pessoas em 88 países diferentes
receberam ajuda do programa alimentar
não são uma história é uma fusão de
tantas histórias que nos deixa de captar
nossa atenção às Nações Unidas também
disseram que o propósito de academia o
risco de morrer à fome quase que
duplicou a passou de 130 para 260
milhões no mundo inteiro o que isso nos
diz isto isto estávamos algo ruim
preparação e se faz nos respeitar por
buraquinho e sair do nosso o nosso
projeto cultural não isso nos casos a
reação nenhuma porque isso não tem
história tem muita representatividade
mas não tenho o poder de uma história de
12 minutos tem o poder de uma história
de que 97 milhões de pessoas não têm
isto é uma forma que
e a mim desperta muita curiosidade sobre
a forma como os nossos
neurotransmissores funcionam em 1993 um
fotógrafo jornalista americano tirou
esta fotografia naquilo que agora o
Sudão do Sul ele relata que veste a
rapariga com o aproximar-se Durante
algum tempo não faz nada depois lá acaba
por afastar o adulto da situação parece
que a rapariga a menina estaria sozinha
porque os pais estavam a receber comida
do mesmo avião onde o jornalista tinha
acabado de chegar a pesar de ter
recebido o prêmio pulitzer por esta
fotografia que foi metaforicamente
conhecida como o desespero da África
também conhecida como a fotografia mais
triste do mundo e ele foi interpelado
por muitas pessoas porque é que não fez
o que é que não fizeste nada porque me
ajudaste a menina Pelos vistos tinha
ordens para não tocar nas crianças
subnutridas por risco de infecção ele
acabou por pedir desculpa a opinião
pública por não ter ajudado a rapariga e
mais tarde
e estas histórias não é fazem-nos
perceber a dimensão do problema falar de
números anestesiamos de alguma forma
sobre as questões mais importantes do
mundo esta ativista humanitária
dinamarquesa chamada anilove encontrou
esta criança que estava abandonada nas
ruas da Nigéria ou de uma cidade da
Nigéria mais de oito meses a família
achava que tinha alguma espécie de
bruxedo Porque ela tinha uma malformação
congênita nos órgãos genitais este
maninho e por isso abandonaram nas ruas
esta rapariga encontrou decidiu um galho
alimentação entregou uma instituição
apoiou passado 8 metros estava assim
vestimos o linho a brincar cheio de vida
é passado um ano ela estava encaminhado
para escola e quando nós falamos sobre a
dimensão da família áfricas estamos não
é não saímos do nosso círculo mas
pensarmos que é uma história que nós
podemos interferir
e nós podemos interferir numa história
recebemos o poder que estas
circunstâncias podem ter em nós
a guerra da Síria começou em 2011 mas
para a maioria das pessoas que só terá
tirasse o maior espectro de atenção em
2014 essencialmente por dois motivos
Primeiro as atitudes bárbaras do Estado
islâmico que assassinaram ocidentais e
como são ocidentais passam ser parte da
nossa história e depois os refugiados
que por coincidência também terá a ver
com o maior terror do Estado islâmico
nesta altura começam a bater-nos à porta
enquanto eles lá estão porque já vi
refugiados não estava na Turquia na
Jordânia no Líbano parte que não tem que
levar tem a porta da Europa a histórias
é um bocadinho mais difícil de nós
começamos a perceber a mente a guerra da
Síria uma coisa muito séria uma história
de uma família de refugiados e
particularmente importante era um pai e
uma mãe duas crianças e eles tinham
estavam a tentar fazer a imigração para
o Canadá tinha lá familiares Pelos
vistos o processo ficou incompleto
faltam alguns papéis alguns dados no céu
certos e então ele lá decidiu
uma das travessias e legais com
traficantes de pessoas naqueles
barquinhos numa distância apenas de 4 km
pagou quatro mil euros para que a sua
pequena família pudesse fazer esta
pequena travessia e resultado foi este
alancourt a criança de 2 anos perdeu
também o irmão EA mãe ou neste caso a
mulher do Senhor que foi a única pessoa
que ficou viva nesta história
é mas eu acredito que para a maioria das
pessoas se calhar o tema dos refugiados
ao cerne das questões humanitárias mas é
um bocadinho que mais crises epilépticas
da Maria é um sintoma não é doença as
doenças são os conflitos armados se a
história do elenco por dia representa
Cerca de 80 milhões de pessoas que estão
refugiados neste momento 36 milhões das
quais são crianças a mais de 400 milhões
que vivem só de crianças que vivem sob
os 10 países mais afetados pelos
conflitos que já estiverem quase todos
eles para mim não são números primos são
histórias de pessoas mas se quisermos
outro número na guerra da Síria o antes
dela começar virtualmente todas as
crianças e uma escola dois anos mais
tarde em finais 2013 dois milhões de
crianças não iam à escola na Síria
detestei a dimensão de um conflito é
aqui que nós temos que empregar todo o
nosso sentido de humanidade infinita
muito pouca gente fala destas histórias
desses
as pessoas não debatem a porta Nós não
sabemos Quem são não sabemos que língua
falam sabemos muito pouco esta criança
para mim representa algo muito poucas
histórias contam É parece que a pessoa
saiu do corpo não ri não chora nós
fingimos que eu não existe e ele também
parece não existir está intacto pelo
sexta física que ele sangue não é dele é
do pai ainda assim é o espelho do
sofrimento de uma guerra a outros que
não têm histórias o Iêmen para nós
praticamente desconhecido já morreram
mais de 100 mil crianças só a fome não
tem histórias no a refugiados a
bater-nos à porta não nos dizem nada há
pouco tempo deparei-me com esta história
muito bonita perto do de um sítio onde
os tipos no iema né se a Taís onde as
crianças e os professores resilientes
dentro ainda assim fazer a educação
continuar no meio daquilo que se chama a
maior crise humanitária dos nossos dias
eu confronto me sempre com esta
realidade
O que é toda a gente Sabe aquilo que
aconteceu no onze de setembro 2001 2000
977 pessoas morreram temos histórias de
comentários Netflix músicas tudo e mais
alguma coisa temos a fotografia de todas
elas e perguntaram nos uma história
contarmos uma história que o quem fez
aquilo seria um Saudita EA menita ao
samba Bin Laden que estaria protegido
escondido no Afeganistão pelo regime dos
Taliban e história As Histórias também
tem este efeito perverso não é tem muito
poder contarmos uma história que fez com
que ninguém no planeta de alguma forma
pusesse em causa aquele quer atitude
bélica que não se inclusive de invadir o
Afeganistão e dois anos mais tarde esta
história serviu também para invadir o
Iraque cerca de um a dois milhões de
pessoas morreram no Afeganistão e no
Iraque nestes últimos anos a propósito
destes conflitos armados eles parem bem
2977 Sabemos um número certo
o cara e os nomes todas as pessoas os
outros entre um milhão e 2 milhões não
tem história não tem histórias nós nos
conectamos mas não respeitamos no
buraquinho para saber quem elas são mas
não temos dentro do Círculo esta menina
uma fotografia que de alguma forma pois
o Afeganistão na capa da Nação
geográfica era uma refugiada na altura
no em território paquistanês da Guerra
dos africanos contra os soviéticos e 17
anos mais tarde foi encontrada pelo
mesmo jornalista agora já no Afeganistão
e que me faz querer saber a história de
algumas pessoas quem são estas pessoas
quem é este povo que não centro 1 milhão
e 2 milhões não sabemos bem com dizer
que morreram
e eu fiquei super contente quando ano
passado este comentário learn how to
skateboard War Zone with your Girl nós
temos as histórias destas meninas a sua
coragem a sua resiliência as suas
dúvidas a sua emancipação de meninas
para adolescentes e para mulheres e
percebemos todos isto aparecem em países
normalmente não queremos saber das suas
histórias mesmo em relação às alterações
climáticas aquilo que pode pôr em
extinção toda a nossa existência às
vezes parece que uma história pode ter
mais poder do que a própria realidade
que o nosso planeta parece ter um prazo
de validade e nós ainda assim mudamos
muito pouco nas nossas vidas né
e eu acredito plenamente que uma
história tem um poder infinito em muitas
circunstâncias as pessoas vêm ter comigo
e pergunto-me o que que eu posso fazer
para ajudar o que que eu devo fazer para
ajudar Estas pessoas estes países pronto
vais não é fácil responder esta pergunta
mas Ouçam as suas histórias contém as
suas histórias e olhem para a vossa vida
como se vocês estivessem escrever um
livro Como Se vocês estivessem a
escrever a vossa história e que um dia
vocês vão olhar para trás e que estavam
em que fosse uma História bonita e Uma
História bonita certamente é uma
história que toca nas histórias de
muitas outras pessoas muito obrigado
E aí
[Aplausos]